cannes polisse merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors je le disais
vous êtes biologistes en première ligne
donc comment est ce que vous avez reçu
les dernières annonces du ministre de la
santé je les gens rappelle quelques une
ouverture de 20 centres de dépistage
priorisation des tests avec des plages
horaires dédiées est-ce que c'est mieux
alors de nous cinglant vraiment l'effort
de clarification et l'information du
grand public et j'ai envie de dire enfin
le ministre de la santé reconnaît qu'il
ya des problèmes organisationnels et
vraiment aux besoins impératifs horaires
et la forme vraiment les français sont
besoin impératif de vraiment prioriser
et est donc voilà nos besoins de
priorisation est vraiment très important
et il essaye de me mettre en pratique
donc effectivement avec des notions de
rendez-vous de brainware voilà tous des
mesures que nous attendions des centres
vote supplémentaires pour peut-être un
petit peu désengorger le laboratoire qui
sont à bout de souffle depuis des
semaines les français les médias le
constate et enfin le gouvernement la
firme donc sur ce programme concerne
nous sommes satisfaits alors ces
nouvelles mesures de priorisation est ce
qu'elles vont être faciles à mettre en
place selon vous alors il faut savoir
que ça fait déjà plusieurs semaines que
droite pour travail sur la priorisation
des tests avec voilà on était en
démesure des directives qui sont donnés
par le ministère est en pratique
c'est vrai que nous avons un petit peu
du mal notamment par exemple sur les
passants symptomatique ou baissent si
vous voulez dès que quelqu'un se
présente au drive il peut de suite
affirmé qu' il va avoir le nez qui coule
des mâts des maux de tête de la fia je
ne pouvais pas vraiment je suis
activités et nous ne parlerons pas
vérifié c'est pour ça que nous demandons
vraiment besoin de passer par un rendez
vous chez le médecin d'une ordonnance
qui certifiera que la personne a
vraiment des symptômes vraiment en biens
un argumentaire qu'unique qui pourraient
être expliquées par coronavirus c'est
que la vitesse devient vraiment
déterminant à faire pour confirmer le
diagnostic pré déjà établi par le
médecin haut niveau au vu des symptôme
l'épiné qui vont également vous venir en
aide
on l'a appris ce matin ils pourront
réaliser des tests c'est une bonne idée
c est une bonne idée ça permet d élargir
encore un petit peu plus le nombre de
prêts verts parce qu'il y est c'est vrai
qu'on avait fait appel
pendant l'été a beaucoup d'étudiants qui
malheureusement maintenant rentrer à
l'université
après reste à savoir si les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes seront vraiment
intéressés et se rendront disponibles
puisque je me doute que aussi en leur
propre rendez-vous consultation à gérer
donc c'est pas là on n'essaie pas une
évidence qui va y avoir une réelle
conséquence pour nous aider au niveau
des prélèvements il faut acheter du
matériel c'est lourd comme dispositif va
mettre en place
oui il faut acheter du matériel nous en
avons commandé depuis des mois parce que
nous aurions nous voyons que ça va venir
petit à petit voilà le nombre de
demandes au vu de la doctrine
gouvernement pas être les mises en place
et voilà on passe on finit sa part iv
mais au coin de route et gratuitement
sur tous les programmes de réactifs donc
ces deux petits bémols à une
intervention du ministre que je te le
mettre en évidence même curieux que et
bien il a affirmé qu' il n'y avait pas
de programme de réactifs qu'il n'y
aurait pas de pénurie
voilà nous nous y constatons jour en
jour voilà où certains laboratoires sont
en parfaite pénurie comme le mien
avec un fournisseur américain qui l'a
nommé fois plus depuis quasiment deux
mois donc c'était la demande à d'autres
à d'autres laboratoires mais c'est vrai
que d'autres de mes confrères part d'une
visibilité à des x 4 5 jours sans avoir
la certitude les attendre pour pouvoir
assurer la continuité de réalisation de
la poussière
ça veut dire quoi très concrètement que
vous n'avez pas le matériel nécessaire
pour pour réaliser les tests finalement
vous n'arrivez plus à être livrés c'est
ça ce que vous nous dites très
concrètement
belga la pénurie avec les réactifs elle
est quasi permanente depuis des mois
mais brel ne se règle pas on voit qu'au
moment de demande augmente à chaque
semaine donc on fera ce que j'ai envie
de vous dire que quand enfin on arrive à
se mettre à niveau
le nombre de demandes continuent
d'augmenter donc on a toujours j'ai un
petit peu en train de en train de retard
au niveau au niveau de la politique de
tests c'est pour ça qu'on demandait de
manière urgente de prioriser parce que
voilà dans mon sein des à la base des
laboratoires qui faisons du diagnostic
ciblé faire du dépistage de masse nous
avons fait des efforts énormément
conséquent pour s'aligner et atteindre
les objectifs de vagues de la doctrine
du ministre de la santé
mais malheureusement nous on n'a pas les
moyens de les tester soit 70 millions de
français tous les jours c'est impossible
comment est le moral des troupes si je
puis dire aujourd'hui chez les
laborantins très mal très mal
vous avez pu le constater peut-être ces
derniers jours des mouvements de grève
ont commencé voilà chez le personnel du
laboratoire qui en plus de la charge de
travail voire à vis des moments très
difficiles d'accueil notamment face à
l'agressivité et aux réactions que
peuvent avoir des patients vis à vis des
délais voilà qui est qui s'allonge des
fois malheureusement et père et
personnes doivent eux des qu'avec des
vols annulés des rendez-vous ne pas
pouvoir reprendre au travail au moment
où s'y attendait et c'est le personnel
qui est en première ligne que je salue
d'ailleurs malheureusement fait fait
énormément cette agressivité qui en plus
de la charge de travail du travail de
nuit des heures supplémentaires on va
pas se le cacher le personnel de
laboratoire et à bout ainsi que des
biologistes médicaux qui voit là
commence à vraiment parce que nous
sommes finalement sont au front un
depuis des mois en fait depuis quasiment
deux mois de mars avec sans arrêt des
modifications augmentation des demandes
toujours toujours plus importante
donc c'est vrai que nous nous vivons une
période difficile et dans la durée et on
n'a pas l'impression que c'est près de
se terminer
merci beaucourt donc à morgane nous
lisent l'avoir accepté notre invitation
je rappelle que vous êtes biologiste